[Music]
why did you
decide to turn the ship around
physically
after getting sober at 31
and emerging from that treatment center
where i lived for a hundred days which
is pretty long time to be in a treatment
center
and being told by the counselors that
you have a very serious case of
alcoholism the kind of case that we
typically only see in lifelong drinkers
like guys in their 60s
it was impressed upon me that i really
needed to get this right or
you know i could
you know i was going to die like it was
just
that point was made to me
very clearly and i was able to hear it
and take it seriously
and so i was super dedicated to
creating this foundation of of sobriety
because my life truly did hang in the
balance and so that became my
main priority
for
many years after that experience so i
returned to los angeles
i was going to multiple meetings a day i
was doing like all the stuff and and
building a new community of friends
because i needed i needed new people you
know i just i couldn't hang out or go to
the places that i had had you know have
been had been going to before
um and with that was also
you know unpacking the shame that i had
about being this person who had all of
this potential
and all of these opportunities that i
had squandered and
i felt compelled to repair all of that
and get back to becoming that person
that i was before i started drinking
and i did that with blinders on in my
mind the best way to do that was to
go back to the law firm and you know
work my ass off and become a partner and
you know get all the stuff so that the
world would smile upon me and my parents
would think that i was safe
alcoholics anonymous is spiritual
program and i was developing spiritually
but i had not yet reached the level of
maturity where
i could really look inward and ask
myself those fundamental questions about
what it is that i actually wanted to do
rather than thinking what is society
expecting me to do
but what is unique to me what gets me
excited in the morning what do you think
that you're here to express that is
uniquely you like that just was not part
of my
you know mental process in in any way
and so
a lot of those addictive
personality traits although i was not
using substances anymore or channeled
into workaholism
and in turn some pretty unhealthy
lifestyle habits so basically 80 hour
weeks
working as a lawyer
and you know hitting the fast food
drive-throughs on the way home and
chinese take out for late nights at work
and and the like and really despite the
fact that i'd been this swimmer in
college not exercising just not really
attending to or taking care of myself
physically
and so over a 10-year period that
accumulates
such that by the time i was 39 i was
about 50 pounds overweight you know
never like an obese person or anything
like that but just kind of like a heavy
guy who looks like you know he works he
works too much in a law firm
and subsisting on junk food and just
feeling progressively worse and worse
lazier
not energized not enthusiastic about my
life
and i think in the in the back of my
awareness was this percolating
existential crisis because i knew that
this career path that i had chosen
was really not for me and i could will
myself into doing it but ultimately it
was not only not making me happy it was
making me more and more
miserable like this square peg and a
round hole kind of thing
but i was too afraid to really look at
that or think about how i could change
that trajectory and there was so i guess
what i'm saying is there was a
confluence of
of poor health
uh on the one side and this you know
spiritual existential crisis that i was
harboring on the other hand
and they essentially collided with each
other
shortly before i turned 40 when i had
this specific moment of
you know walking up the flight of stairs
in my bedroom after
a late night at the office
and i had to like stop halfway up a
flight of stairs like i was too winded
to just walk all the way to the top and
i had tightness in my chest and
and you know kind of like i was had that
sweaty power on my face from
from a flight of stairs and thinking i'm
like this person who would swam at
stanford and would look in the mirror
and see that person reflected back to me
i realized that i was harboring a whole
other level of of denial that i needed
to look at and it was a scary moment
because heart disease runs in my family
my mother's father
had been a champion swimmer and captain
of the university of michigan swim team
in the
late 1920s and early 30s and and you
know a guy who had an american record
and somebody who he's a guy that i'm
named after and in many ways like my
doppelganger but he had died of heart
disease at a young age
and i had this flash where
i realized if i didn't course correct
how i was living that i was
likely headed in his direction
and would meet my demise probably sooner
than he had because there was no
mcdonald's and jack in the box when he
was kicking around
um and it was so it was sort of like a
second bottom that was very reminiscent
of the day i decided to get sober like
this very crystallized moment in time
where it's almost like a window of
opportunity
presents itself like a a crack in the
door or a line in the sand
and you have this opportunity to
to harness it uh take advantage of it
and
and
take contrary action
or not right and because i was so aware
of how that simple decision of going to
that treatment center had changed my
life so dramatically
that i was being once again visited by
just such a moment i realized that i
needed to take action swiftly because if
i didn't kind of grab onto it
immediately i knew
it would just pass and become ephemera
and so that was really
the moment that that catalyzed kind of
everything that that followed and even
you know
the fact that i'm talking to you today
it all tracks back to that very specific
incident
you